and in other news First Responders are
often trained on saving people as well
as pets but what if that pet weighs
hundreds of pounds I-8 news now reporter
Victoria Saha took a trip up to Newark
Las Vegas to see how First Responders
were shown the ropes on handling gentle
Giants
during case of an emergency
we'll halter horses and lead them to
Safety in case they ever have to respond
to a ranch fire
there's plenty of horses in northwest
Las Vegas
but what if a fire came to a ranch
that's what's on Horses for Heroes Ranch
owner Sydney Knott's mind when some fire
zones the right thing to do is to let
them go in this Urban environment that
would not be the right thing to do and I
wonder how does anybody know how to get
these animals to safety it would be up
to First Responders
so not hosted an evacuation drill on her
Ranch her team showed North Las Vegas
fire and Animal Control how to safely
handle livestock you want to walk side
by side shoulder to shoulder with the
horse not only did they learn to lead a
horse safely into the trailer
foreign
but studying their body language is key
their ears are pinned back they start
picking up their back leg
they're about to fire you off a kick for
animal control it isn't anything like
the other four-legged creatures they
deal with it's a skill that you have to
continue to practice to be comfortable
with and for firefighter Jacob Albrecht
it's his first time touching these
gentle Giants with the amount of ranches
that are throughout the valley it's a
good learning experience the owners of
this Ranch say they want to offer their
training to other agencies because
Nevada is home to many domestic and wild
horses reporting from Lone Mountain I'm
Victoria Saha this is Jax eight news now